thing thing what thing thing thing that
you do what's that
because we don't know how to do the
other thing without you doing your thing
it's the cute hey guys I'm Ryan Wright
olicity crazy you did the thing cooked
in cyber we're gonna watch the trailer
for Batman Arkham Knight AE scam Ackles
infiltration filtration trailer part 2
my night up there we go Batman yes
Batman if case you guys I know who that
is
he actually if you guys don't know who
that is wait that you you don't deserve
to know you obviously been left out for
a reason anyway first trailer was cool
let's watch this one yes the first
trailer was amazing
Oh why'd you do that to yourself
god damn those eyes
[Music]
goddamn pegs
these pages also attack
I remember that
[Music]
and
[Music]
so much yes I look so badass it does
look pretty [ __ ] cool I must admit I
must admit there's like the six trailer
I've seen for this and or fifth and it
just looks cool or each and every time
it really does question the answer I I
think he just killed like exactly I was
thinking that no I was totally thinking
that like I thought Batman some big rule
was you can't [ __ ] murder any I think
he just anyways like blowing up people
and he doesn't use guns either and he's
like hey you know what probably
something we don't know there's probably
the equivalent to like a roll cage or
something in there a roll cage which
justifies murder oh okay oh yeah they
could be totally fine inside oh their
machinery is yeah I blew up he's
exploding the tank some of them look
like small like black holes and like
imploded it tunnels now I mean it's cool
and all but it does kind of go against
the Batman character which does bother
me I don't know if that's his French I
noticed with Batman though is even
though he doesn't really kill people he
leaves people to die and he just he
bounces so we don't actually know if he
intends to kill them or not he just kind
of bounces know what they happen inside
they die but he's not but Batman is so
personal about it like that's the whole
reason he's a hero is because the one
thing he does not do is kill or else I
will make him just like everyone he
hates so he's so anti killing it makes
me go huh I don't know it's like Batman
doing that yeah we've seen him do that
before but Batman straight up like
annihilate people it's like whoa this is
crazy do we actually that's a lie we saw
him get in a Batmobile my train of
thought is nullified never mind
yeah unless Morgan Freeman has been
controlling the whole thing he just kind
of sits in there it's like well I'm not
technically feeling up it is bored and
Freeman doing the hard work for me
Batman
shall I fire the Bissell spot I may be
its Alfred instead I can't do a Michael
Caine now play you weren't doing
and more different do it I was doing me
and that's what's important kids you do
you and I'll do me
and then we'll go get some tea so you
want them to masturbating you masturbate
and then and suddenly or gasps let me
get tea deep Batman it's actually really
cool his eyes though those were
beautiful yeah now the detail on all the
characters is always the pleasure to
look at in the cinematic effects even in
like it's very even in like Arkham
Asylum like just back then it was like
you have a cinematic effects are [ __ ]
awesome these effects are just they're
even better and I like the music it kind
of reminded me of like the Daft Punk
Tron music a little bit can we take a
second and appreciate the new and
improved Batmobile how it can just kind
of go in your new Wow go in it and do
all the different things it is amazing
also that it's a murder weapon now aside
away no it's still pretty cool yeah let
me [ __ ] if you're gonna play as
Batman I want the option to kill people
I think it should be an option
dear God anyway guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and you can subscribe to
Dan's gaming channel that cyber Channel
and Alyssa's vlog and challenges and
other [ __ ] videos anymore subscribe
until this is channel they're fun I
promise I didn't mean your videos are
[ __ ] I was saying like others shut bad
that's how do you win it's all came out
I'm sorry and that's not that's how this
[ __ ] came out huh sure how about a Bing
badda press all the buttons
phantom news 0-1
hey Ryan shout-out what up my man your
vids are awesome you want to know why
because the colors of the alphabet can
and March on the fields of oppression
towards your kingdom do you put a
magical spell above your castle so that
the Illuminati can never steal your soul
that's why dad - Musa ye and hail baked
Haley perfect so ya fat to me is 0-1 um
Wow you've successfully completed your
own shoutout there's nothing more I
could say John Yin could you shout me
out
I have sixteen subs wanting to buyer to
collab I make short films and skits do
now John Yin ha my Asian friend people
say them I they think I might be racist
so I'm gonna straight away from Asian
jokes even though you totally look like
I could totally bag on you that's just
sorry taken successfully make fun of in
a very serious way anybody on the face
of the earth given somebody that would
be a challenge and he can do it yeah but
I'm not a racist in real life well no
but you can't like it's the same as like
Family Guy like it's an honor to be made
fun of in Family Guy and it's in the
worst anyway subscribe to John yams
channel he is um he's totally a unique
Asian guy everything about him just
strays away from stereotypes showing
that you don't have to conform to
normality thank you John yet Michael
Jackson I'm Michael Jackson where's my
shoutout and reply this is my reply to
you Michael Jackson
oh no wait you can't is it's not okay to
make the Michael Jackson joke still is
it because he's new girl Michael did it
in 2009 so that's way to make oh Michael
Jackson my graduation party so it's not
too early right past it depends on it
you want to be tasteful or not well I
mean our most people might not taste a
little battered on the entertainment
world they still make jokes about
Michael Jackson being a weirdo if you
want to insult the King of Pop I mean
that's up to you I mean well when you
put it like that down
want to insult the King of Pop but the
King of Pop mom he makes fun of
everybody that's your most genuine reply
you'll ever get